Okay, Dr. Bell, if you would please introduce yourself for the
you name and today's date and our location.
David Bellott and today is July what?
July 9th.
Okay, July 9th.
2014 and we're located at my place on the Portable in Cabin.
Terrific.
What's the start of the beginning?
You're born in Grinch, Connecticut.
Grinch, Connecticut?
Grinch, Connecticut, 1938.
And were you raised there?
I was raised there pretty much.
You have my whole life until I went to college.
Can you tell us about sort of your experience of Grinch growing up?
Well, Grinch is an interesting place.
It's a powerful place.
A lot of millionaires.
We were one of my dad was principal of high school.
And I went to the same high school.
And I think I really learned about leadership.
He was very good.
He said if you spend more than 50% of your time in your office,
you're not doing your job.
So as a student, he knew what was going on.
I was amazed.
None of the students ever gave me any hassle.
They said he was tough but he's fair.
And he learned all sorts of things.
And he did this by getting down to the trenches.
I mean, he'd go down the boiler room and just talk with the maintenance people.
He'd talk with the people serving up food and cafeteria.
And he wouldn't ask him for anything.
They would just tell him because they were part of the team.
So I learned that kind of leadership from him.
Unfortunately, we don't see that kind very often.
What were your parents' backgrounds?
My dad was a physicist.
I went to Yale.
And he became high school principal and physical physics teacher.
And my mother was a pianist at the concert pianist.
She died when I was four.
But I can still remember sitting under the piano while she practiced.
And we did quite a bit of camping.
And my dad ran some of our camps for churches, Lutheran Church.
And I wanted a lot about nature then.
And I respect the nature from these big camps.
And I had a lot of these.
And their idea for helping kids was to get them into nature.
And that's what they did.
So I had that background.
And my beginning of environmental concerns came out of the church background in the summer camps.
Did you have any siblings?
I had three sisters.
And older sister.
And two younger sisters.
And how was the household managed after your mother passed?
Well, my father remarried several times.
And I just treated it as a normal household.
He was a very good mentor.
And he had male friends who ran these summer camps.
And I had an analogue who was quite a doer.
I never thought that women couldn't do anything men could do.
Because my aunt, my aunt, obviously could.
So they just never occurred to me.
And so that was the household.
We sort of in the country, not quite like this.
But spent a lot of time outdoors.
That was good.
What were your interest as a boy besides being outdoors?
How doors, building tree huts?
I guess that was it.
I wasn't into, I played sports, but not, you know, not really that much.
So just hanging around about doors and doing stuff, I guess.
Did you enjoy school?
Yeah, I enjoyed it.
I was not particularly in high school, a great student.
Like most kids at age, I enjoyed seeing my friends and seeing my friends and that's what I did.
So what were your first inclinations towards science or engineering?
Oh, I don't know.
I think I was always, I want to do something.
And so I don't think I really, I mean, I was pretty good at science.
It was interesting.
Engineering seemed more like you were going to do something.
So I just sort of, it wasn't any big decision.
I did decide to go to the Virginia Military Institute, which anybody knows is a pretty tough place to go, particularly that first year you're a rat.
We'll take me through the process of making that decision.
Why, why VMI?
Well, VMI, I guess I say it's tough.
I look around a lot, you know, when you're growing up, kids, boys, at least.
What's a matter of can't you take it, a place sort of those games and you think, well, when I get older, I don't have to play those games.
As I get, as I got older though, I saw a lot of men were playing those games.
Same thing.
I mean, I see it all the time at Oregon State University, people getting caught up and afraid to speak up.
So I said, I'm just going to go there.
Then, you know, it's tough.
And if anybody says, what's the matter?
Can't you take it?
I'll just laugh at him.
I mean, you go through the rat line.
It's pretty tough.
So I think that was the way I thought of it.
And it generally worked that way.
It was tough.
And you saw as a challenge that you wanted to take on.
It was a challenge, that's right.
And I saw it as a challenge to take on.
And I wasn't planning career military.
I wasn't looking for a disciplined life.
It was a challenge.
And I think the MI's nurtured that.
You know, he's had a Maverick spirit.
Very rigid, tough discipline, but there was always.
There was a tension there, a creative tension.
And so I thought of the word challenge as a positive word.
And something's challenging.
You know, my eyes light up on.
OK, what are we going to do about it?
So it was a good education.
Class sizes were about 2022.
And I had some pretty remarkable people there.
Jonathan Daniels was a martyr in the civil rights movement.
And he was a seminary student when he left the MI,
become an Episcopal priest.
And he got killed there.
That really jolted the South, unfortunately.
You know, Jonathan had to give his life forward.
But he was quite a person.
He's a valvictorian of our class.
Well, what was the environment like it be in my, especially that first year?
Oh, the first year you're a rat.
At first year, you're on the go all the time.
It's physically and mentally demanding.
It can cycle logically demanding.
But all your classmates are in the same boat.
So it's not like they're picking on you.
I mean, you're all in it together.
And there are times when you say, well, they can't kill me.
And this isn't going to last forever.
And somehow that would get you through.
And I thought of that years later, in terms of racial prejudice,
because people can't say that.
They couldn't say that.
And when I went back to one of my reunions,
one of the most impressive things that happened to me.
There was an older guy there that was a maintenance person.
And he was black.
And I told him what year I was there.
And I think he says, well, that's when he began.
And he comes in and gives me this big hug
and we're celebrating together.
And it felt really good.
It really did.
And they've integrated down there,
because it was not integrated when I'm like there.
And they've done a really good job.
And there's men and women down there now.
And so not integrated as in it was white.
And you were there were white classes of white classes.
It was almost all white.
I think probably was all white.
And just in the south that, you know,
as people just didn't even think of it.
And Jonathan did.
He gave his life for it.
Well, when they decided when they,
they figured, man, this is a serious problem.
They really set out to correct it.
And they really did.
And we've had some remarkable graduates, white end black,
and patient and so on.
It was, you know, I would say turning point in my life.
I mean, to see that change is wonderful.
What else was expected of students there besides the coursework?
Well, you had physically demanding.
And of course, you first year, you're harassed.
I mean, you're in the rat line.
You're a rat.
And you're on the go all the time.
And so it's hard to describe.
I mean, the Marines respect it.
And I've had several Marines say, yeah, it's tough.
And for a Marine, that's probably about the best compliment you can get.
And it's mutual.
I mean, that's a lot of physical training and military drilling, I see.
Well, there's not a particularly a lot of drilling.
You had parades that you did and you marched and you were uniforms.
But the academics were very good.
And classes were small.
And there were, you know, they were academically very good.
So it's just tough schedule.
Physically demanding.
I mean, if you got a chance to take a nap, you'd lay down for 15 minutes and go to sleep and wake up and start all over again.
But during the day, you didn't even have your beds down.
And you rolled up the mattresses there up against the, you know, rolled up.
And we called it a hay rack.
That was leaned against the wall.
And even it was, it was pretty rigid.
But you'd always had sort of a maverick spirit to it.
You know, when night we tried it, we put the evening gun.
And I don't know, 90 millimeter hours are in the PX.
You know, snuck out there.
I mean, there'd be things you'd sort of do that way.
And things, things would happen.
So it was, you learn some things like pulling rank.
That's really bad.
I mean, if you, somebody does something.
Yeah, you got ranking.
Of course, you know, a dean or a president has to do things.
Every responsibility, we all know that.
But if they do something, and it's only because I got the rank.
That's pulling rank.
And that's not looked on pretty well.
In fact, they'd have a parade.
And in the parade, there'd be a flanking movement.
The troops here, companies have been told in circles.
Going online.
And the officer was a kid at officer.
But being a front with a saber marching in the front.
And there would be tack officers grading the lines.
Well, if he had pulled rank, those lines would just go like this.
And then he'd get chewed out.
So they, you know, if you pulled rank, we throw lines.
So I mean, it was, it was just pulling rank was not,
not considered a particularly good thing.
I see more of it going on at Oregon State University.
And people sort of accepting it.
That's the part that drives me nuts.
You know, someone says something.
It does something that doesn't make sense.
People like and courteous, but tell them.
A lot of times they, you know, they may get upset.
But they really, the best ones know they need to not hear that.
But I've seen just too many people with this blank face.
Just don't say anything.
You can't do it.
Well, I mean, how your academic life sort of evolved while you're at EMI?
Well, I actually got better grades and college than I did in high school.
And I ended up with a civil engineering degree.
And I, you know, I don't know whether I had any career aspirations of that.
It was like you're entering a big open space.
You know, you're entering the future.
So I didn't have an agenda.
What I wanted to do, what I wanted to be.
I wanted to do something.
Do something interesting.
I was more scouting sort of explore.
So I guess, and I think at the EMI,
I think they encouraged that.
You'd ask questions in class.
And I thought it was a good education, not a way.
And there were bad teachers, yeah.
But they always are.
But you learned from them, too.
So yeah.
Well, you took that education in your first job as with the Division of Indian Health.
Yes, public health service.
Right.
The US Public Health Service Indian Health, and I went to New Mexico and loved it.
And it was sanitary engineers that called them.
And we put in water and sewer systems in Indian pueblos.
And I bring in translators.
And then I got transferred to state of Washington.
It was kind of funny because they said, well, there's a project that has a little bit of a problem.
Any time a government agency says we have a little bit of a problem.
That means it's a disaster.
So when I got up there, the project engineer, it wasn't either there.
And it turns out that some wanted to punch them out.
And after listening to the stories, I began to understand why.
But yeah, we got the project lined up.
But even there, there were some things you had to do.
Like they didn't have enough parts to keep the cruise busy.
Well, if you look at the government procedures, it takes months to get the parts.
Your budget's going to be gone.
Or either that or you have to lay off the crew.
And so I just went out and told them, wrote a memo and said,
I'm going to go and buy some parts wholesale.
And if this is a problem, please call me.
And then I stayed away from the phone.
So I got the parts.
And they were upset because they probably could have saved $30 by going through the GAO or no GSA.
But the loss of money for the crew.
So I mean, you did things like that.
I'd love the crew.
I love the construction.
A lot of funny stories they tell me.
And how do good time?
It's good.
What sort of impact did the living in Indian country make on you?
Well, I actually, in Albuquerque, I was living in Albuquerque.
And I go on the reservation.
And in the state of Washington, I live off reservation.
But it was more in the state of Washington, more like rural country.
And I loved the culture, loved the dances.
And it was a really good experience for me.
So I sort of participated in it.
I mean, broke my wrist riding rodeo.
So I had a little bit of some good stories to tell.
So that was good.
What did you think of the Pacific Northwest?
I see that was your first exposure to it.
Yeah.
And I only, I was up in the state of Washington.
And I did drive through Oregon.
And then I went over to the coast.
And the thing that impressed me the coast was it was hard to get down to the beach.
There were some really longs.
I mean, or just longs all over the place.
And of course, now there aren't.
And I think there were a lot of wasteful timber practices back then.
And longs were just drift out.
But I really didn't.
I was in Eastern Washington.
And so it's quite different than Carvalas.
I mean, I liked it.
I liked the beautiful country.
Well, after a year or two, I think with that job, you went back to school.
Yeah.
I spent a little over a year or two years in public health service.
Then I went back to New York University.
Right in the middle of New York City.
What it changed.
I mean, holy.
I'm out in the sticks and my palms and a cast from the radio accident.
I'm ending up ending up in New York, middle of New York City.
But I did get a good education there at New York University.
And I got into computer modeling.
And this was back in the mid-60s.
So I got into that.
Fort Tran was pretty new then.
And I did sort of learn machine language, which was awful.
Fort Tran, though, was great.
I had a very good major professor.
And I got into computer simulation long before most people.
There were no PCs back then.
And there was no internet.
I used to take cards down on the subway to the Greenwich Village.
That's where the Cron Institute of Mathematics was.
And they had a big computer then.
You'd give them the cards and they'd run it.
And then you plot by hand the results.
But you got to understand what a model does because you plot them by hand.
You did them yourself.
You could actually see what was going on in the computer.
And now a lot of people don't see that.
They really don't understand that.
And consequently, I think there's a lot of misuse of computer models now.
What's the things we're modeling?
Lakes and estuaries.
And the thing about estuaries is they're part of the river that's influenced by the ocean.
And the tides come in and out.
They're very dynamic systems.
Waters changing.
And so before the digital computer, you had to make mathematical assumptions of steady state.
And the sanitary engineers have been doing this since 1925.
When I'm rivers building mathematical models long before the scientists were doing it.
And actually the rivers got better.
They did a lot.
There was a lot of good.
And that's sort of been airbrushed out of the history.
We may come back to that later.
Because there was a lot of environmental improvements on rivers in particular that occurred there.
And I was part of that history.
But the 60s things were changing.
We knew things were changing.
We saw lakes were having problems.
So all sorts of problems.
And so that was a real era of transformation.
When I got here, the computer and the pre-exciting time.
Was this also your first experience of teaching?
Yeah, my first experience in teaching formally.
I used to help.
I used to do some help sessions for some of my classmates back at me and my family has a lot of teachers.
And so I loved it.
So I loved the students and teaching.
And I like the research.
I don't like proposal writing.
We'll come back to that later.
Tell me about living in New York City in the 60s.
Well, you know, I was mainly involved in graduate school.
And there were some protests.
I generally was not part of that.
My...
It was part of the protest.
I was part of the sense of let's do something about the problems.
And mainly pollution.
And certainly Martin Luther King Jr. had a profound effect on me.
And this is a huge transformation.
And it was...
That was a good time.
I think that what happened a little bit after that,
the drug scene and other things.
I just... I felt like that was very different, very self-indulf.
And often destructive.
And so I really... I had a mixed feelings.
I really identified, yes.
Let's make the world a better place.
But there also seemed to be sort of a self-centered navenous
that was associated with this.
And maybe a tendency to blame other people rather than saying what can we do.
So I had a mixed... it was a mixed feeling, mixed bag.
Was this... is it fair to say this was sort of the beginnings of your environmental
consciousness that come before?
Oh, environmental consciousness came before.
It came largely through the churches.
And again, that's been a whole history that they don't talk about.
You probably have had that.
You probably took the history of environmental from Bob McDermott.
And that's just not included.
Well, it was huge.
I mean, my father would have 300 boys out in this...
cabins out there and they had nature counselors.
And across the river of the lake was a girls camp.
And there was another teenage camp.
Young adults camp there.
And this was a big thing.
And so I was always taught that respect.
And it was also a sort of a technology.
Well, it's got some good things, but it's got some limitations too.
So we also had that.
And when I got here at Oregon State University,
it was the campus ministries that were challenging higher education.
There's a guy, John Connor, you oughta just do a separate history on John Connor.
And because he probably did more to change Oregon State University than any other person here.
He was a campus minister with Mr. House.
And we would have classes there on environmental problems and appropriate technology.
So it was a big thing.
And there were some economics theories.
Kenneth Bowling and Herman Daley.
Dick Clinton is in a view him.
He'll tell you about Herman Daley.
And academia just sort of closed that stuff off.
And but at the time in the late 60s and early 70s it was pretty exciting.
I mean, there was a lot of interesting things that were happening.
But that movement died out.
And again it's sort of been airbrushed out of the history.
And I think this is one of the things that's probably important for oral history.
Because a lot of historians they studied the archives.
Well, the stuff that may be most important didn't make it into the archives.
Because the big institutions basically don't fund that.
And so it sort of disappears.
So we need to have people take oral history and say, look, here's some good stuff.
And it makes a lot of sense.
Kenneth Bowling, Herman Daley.
I mean you go back.
EF Schumacher, small as beautiful.
I mean, these are books that came in books of writings and speeches that were amazing.
I mean Kenneth Bowling.
He's one of the best speakers I heard on any economist.
And he studied terribly.
And you'd sit there and you'd first be nervous.
And then you'd realize that it doesn't bother him.
So it didn't bother you.
It was amazing.
And he came up with some really good stuff.
I think if we weren't in no way to deal with some of the environmental problems we have now.
Go back and look at them.
And Kenneth Bowling, he was a Quaker.
Herman Daley, I think, was a Methodist.
EF Schumacher Catholic.
This was a spiritual movement.
But it was...
It was...
And nothing to do with intelligent design or evolution or anything like that.
It was never an issue.
And so that's a part of the history.
People want to understand what we're at.
We're at now.
I think we can go back and say there were some opportunities that were missed.
That happened.
I'll come back to some of those.
Sure.
We'll tell me about the decision to come to OSU.
1967 you graduated from NYU.
You came here.
Yeah.
I don't think I sing aloud OSU for any reason.
In fact, I had applied to EPA.
And they were going to hire me.
And Tom Baumgartner was over EPA.
And the hire me on a uterification study of lakes.
And also, estuaries.
Tom was estuaries.
Anyhow.
A Quatic ecosystem.
And somehow a position fell through.
So he sent my resume over to Fred Berges,
who was the dean of engineering.
And I got this notice.
You know, we'd like a position here.
So I said, yeah.
So I took it.
What was your first impression of the university in the town?
Well, I liked it.
I really, you know, a beautiful campus.
And it still is.
I mean, it's, I mean, it's a few other buildings.
I mean, generally, I think it's, it's a fantastic campus.
The people were, were good or friendly.
So I enjoyed.
What was the department like?
Department was, it was a good department.
It was a traditional engineering department.
But I did have some, some certain amount of freedom.
I started, of course, on mathematical modeling, computer simulation.
And you look back.
And that was a pretty big jump for a lot of the people back then,
because the digital computer was fairly new,
except in military, of course.
And so I had a course there.
I also had a course at graduate course.
Got on the books that was something like a philosophy of technology.
So they, you know, they were receptive to this.
And I think my education and me and my helped a little bit,
because, you know, if I felt strongly about something,
I told them so.
And I think most people appreciated that.
At least they knew that I wasn't going to back off,
because I was afraid of raising something unusual.
They didn't even occur to me.
So I did get some courses taught then.
And at that time, I had the mightest touch.
I could get research grants.
I mean, I was just, you know, I couldn't believe it.
Now they weren't big grants like you get now.
They, but I had, on estuaries, I had one.
And then I had, uh,
beautification as it leaks.
What happens to leaks?
It was a computer simulation.
I got that.
And I had another interesting one.
And, uh, put talk a little more about that.
And that was environmental strategies under indeterminacy.
I think that's what the title was.
And, um, they even funded that.
This is a small grant.
Uh, but then the strange things happened.
Uh, as my awareness started to expand,
the funding agency started to go narrower.
And by the end of the 70s, uh, things have changed.
Things have really changed.
What do you think happened?
Well, that's a good story.
And that's the one the historians have to look at.
Now there, there are some historians here, uh,
Army Mother Nature, uh, Jacob Darwin,
Hamlet, uh, great name.
Jacob Darwin, I love it.
And he's written a very good book.
And it's about how the environmental movement,
or the environmental science, more environmental science.
And particularly big computers came out of the military.
And, uh, I didn't know that at that time.
But my background was out of the sanitary engineering.
So it was a whole different background.
And what happened is their way of doing it took over.
And the way we were doing it, shrunk.
And so, what they were saying is,
well, we'll build big computer models.
I'm simplifying it.
And that's how we'll approach the future.
Well, I was in the computer model.
And I said, you can't do, I mean, yeah, build computer models.
But you cannot have environmental strategies,
based on prediction and control.
The world is too complex.
And so, what we did during this study,
what I did during this study,
environmental strategies under indeterminacy.
I said, look, we have a strategy.
It's very simple.
You don't need big models.
You could build big models.
But you need a strategy.
And the strategy is, we will make mistakes.
Okay.
That's called confession.
And so, what you have to do is learn how to make good mistakes.
And a good mistake is, say, reverseable.
Uh, good mistakes are once you learn from.
Good mistakes are once where you don't get painted in a box.
So we came up with a strategy like this.
And it all made very good sense.
And it does to this day.
I mean, you take carbon dioxide, the green asshole.
Uh, people still to try to predict their models
or all over the place if you go far out.
But the CO2 impact is almost irreversible.
And it's just shooting to the sky.
So under that strategy, we would have said, you got to stop.
You can't wait to you find out what the impacts are.
It's too late.
The world is changing faster than you can develop your predictions.
So I thought it all made sense.
So they send when I write my file report in 78.
And I got a copy of it.
One in the file.
They send the guy out there to look over my shoulder while I'm writing it.
And I said, this is strange.
That never happened before.
And I thought maybe it was because the Senator Proxima is golden fleece awards.
He would ridicule scientific projects.
But I realize now after some of the history books coming out,
the parents were changing.
They were saying we want big skill, computer models.
And I was in the modeling book.
So the guy looked over my shoulder and said, okay.
And I thought he was pleased with the report.
He was.
But when he left, he said, we'll never fund anything like this again.
Like, why?
I was shocked.
We don't have a box to put it in.
This is the answer.
Now I didn't realize at that time that that's what the transformation
was occurring.
You're building big boxes.
So you have only little specialized areas to do certain tasks to feed
them to the models.
And we weren't looking at this.
And one of the guys I worked with on here is Scott over to.
Did you interview Scott?
No.
It's a shame.
He passed away.
But there is a website.
You really ought to take a look at it.
Very impressive guy.
And Scott and I probably had earnings stay between the two of us at the time.
We published a paper in 72.
We probably had more environmental computer modeling than any other two
at the university.
And we basically came up with a strategy that was not based on prediction
and control.
And of word large scale irreversible change.
You have to do that because you don't know what the consequences are
be.
So when you make a mistake, you want to make a goodness
stake, which means it can reverse it.
CO2 doesn't reverse.
I mean, it's up there for centuries.
It's sad.
Tell me about overton.
Overton.
Scott overton statistics and forest management.
And Scott, he was very disciplined.
In fact, there were people in statistics.
I think they were afraid of him.
And good guy.
Very thoughtful person.
Very rigorous.
And he was a few years old in my,
I suppose, he was a scout in World War II, I think.
And how you can look up his background.
And statistics and forest management.
And he, he just was good.
So we got together.
And we started talking about this.
And we said, let's write a paper on it.
And it was published in the American Society Civil Engineers,
a sanitary engineering division.
And it really wasn't.
You know, environmental science was just sort of,
that wasn't really out there.
Scott had a student Larry Hutt.
And I think, early 70s, he did his PhD.
And he had to do it in forest management.
There was no ecology.
But it was in ecology, you know, PhD.
We had a graduate faculty of ecology.
We were sort of fighting the system.
And during his, one of his last meetings,
in March as a group of faculty from forest management,
complaining that he didn't take the road design courses
and the cable design, all the stuff about logging.
And, well, he had a powerful committee.
And there was a dean of forestry.
I think his name was Stoneberg.
And I have to get the guy credit.
He picked up the body language of our committee
that we were going to fight for this guy.
And so he was very diplomatic, pretty says.
Well, this time, but we'll arrange this.
So we got him through.
So Larry Hutt was probably one of the first ones
to actually get a PhD in ecology.
So there were other people who had done things in biology.
But it was generally, it's not, you know, like it is now.
So that was interesting.
I'm interested in knowing a little bit more about the climate
on campus in the late 60s.
Obviously it was raging.
There was a lot of tumult nationwide.
What was your sense of the environment on campus itself?
There was, I don't think, I think relative to other places.
There was probably less.
But I think some of the inquiry sort of maybe lasted a little longer.
So it's like some of the places burnt out quicker.
My contact was largely through the campus ministries.
And they were really, they were really active.
Well, the way into the 70s and in fact, even beyond that,
I can remember having a course over Westminster House.
And so I knew the curl of the ROTC curl.
Kurt Rossler, I think, is this name.
And he, I was probably late 70s, I'm guessing.
And I may have the date off, but you can look about his pictures up there.
And he was a tank commander.
And so this is the cold war.
And during cold war, Saudi tanks were, you know, I mean, the armed divisions.
They were powerful.
This was a major concern.
So I brought him over to one of these classes.
And there are a whole lot of what we call hippies.
And in this class, any just wars, whether casual civilian clothes,
any started talking with them.
And they didn't want to like him.
But they did.
He was a good guy.
And I remember asking him the question.
What is a more danger to American society?
The Soviet tank or the American gas goes in car.
And he said, oh, that's easy.
It's the car.
And so, I mean, we had those kinds of discussions that were going on.
They sort of ended late 80s.
Late 80s, we put on a conference on Eisenhower's federal well address.
He warns about the military industrial complex.
But people don't realize he also warned about the university.
And the danger is that the pursuit of government grants and contracts will be pursued
so much that intellectual curiosity will be given up.
We must guard against the scientific technological leader after that.
He says only informed and knowledgeable citizenry can prevent this from happening.
I mean, he has some powerful stuff.
So we did a whole conference on that.
And one of the things we didn't that conference, Craig Walker, you can interview him.
He's the mayor.
He gave a copy of the book.
We did on it.
He and I wrote a chapter at the end.
And we said, suppose George Bush gave this conference.
Because George Bush, the first George Bush was present at that.
And not George W. That was his George W's father.
And so what we did is we took portions of the speech.
And we just said, suppose George Bush wrote this.
And the only thing we'll change is his warning is not about the military industrial complex.
Is the oil industrial complex.
And so we changed.
And it's really a radical.
It comes across really radical.
Well, you can take that and take it for his son.
You can take it and give that speech now.
And he was warning.
I mean, it's remarkable with Eisenhower.
His whole life was in the military industrial complex.
And his final warning is warning about it.
I was very impressed with that.
Yeah.
And your sense was always seen as foreign parade of these warnings.
Oh, yeah.
I think pursuit of the research.
It's not just OSU.
But I think higher education in general.
I mean pursuit of research.
I'm a word graded when I was there.
Research.
I mean, I don't know whether anybody read the papers.
But you sure had to put a list on how much money you brought in.
I think that's pretty pretty common right now.
And so you bring in more money.
And I said, this is strange.
You know, we're being paid.
We rewarded for spending more money.
Why don't we say, look, gee, I did all this interesting stuff.
And I didn't spend very much of the tax payers money.
I mean, it seemed to me that would make sense.
But it didn't work that way.
So was the paper with Overton and 72 is that sort of the beginning of the system's theory work?
Well, the system's theory work first of all in the computer modeling and ecosystems.
I was doing ecosystems.
So I was involved in systems.
And I was involved in some ecologist or limb knowledge,
or just G. Evelyn Hodgson.
And there were a number of people owed them ecology to the beginning of ecology.
So I had used some of their work, met some of those people.
And I was coming at it.
But I began to realize that the rivers aren't the problem.
The trees aren't the problem. The fish aren't the problem.
It's the human systems that are the problem.
So I began to realize this in the 70s, maybe even a little before that.
And so what I started doing was studying human systems.
Now, if you're going to study human systems, kind of, you make a choice.
I mean, I computers.
So I can sit behind a computer, of course they didn't have the computer screens,
but now of course they do.
Or I can actually get out in the organizational systems.
And see what's happening.
I chose that second route.
And that was actually a conscious choice.
I'm going to collect experiences.
I'm not going to be sitting eventually,
but they got computer screens.
I'm not going to be sitting behind a computer screen.
So I never had email on campus.
Never.
Okay.
I have some at home now.
Will gamble.
You can interview him.
I don't know.
He didn't either.
So we were probably the last ones.
But I'm working with these computer systems.
Now, when you work with these computer systems,
there's a whole level of mathematics that you can do.
Not many of your dynamics, emergence.
That you can't do with traditional mathematics.
And, you know, I could explain it.
Take me about three-four minutes.
Explain it because I'd have to explain differential equations.
But basically, you couldn't solve the equations.
And what you would do in differential equations.
You start out with the initial condition.
You tell the rates of change.
And then you can make a prediction.
Okay?
But with certain equations, non-linear.
That's particularly, if they're, say, three-dimensional.
So you're going to see in space, you know, what the predictions are.
You end up with the things going around like this.
It's called chaos.
And you end up with essentially the world is just not that predictable.
And then you're throwing complexity.
And so over tonight, we're on to that, 72.
If you look up the references, one of them, I think the title,
had one plus one, does not equal to.
That is the whole cannot be reduced to some of the parts.
And the other one was a paper by Warren Weaver that basically said,
Science doesn't, does not know how to deal with problems of organized complexity.
So I was into the math.
Okay?
Because with the digital computer, you can approximate the solution
to equations that you cannot solve.
So you don't solve them.
You get a finite difference in numerical methods and approximations.
That's what all the computer simulations are doing now.
They don't solve the equations like they do in differential equations.
They can't.
They can't even come close.
But the non-linear behave in weird ways.
I mean, the non-linear world is bizarre.
And it's only bizarre because for several hundred years,
we've been taught to think linearly.
And when you're taught to think linearly,
then when something non-linear comes up, it seems bizarre.
So I would meet with a guy, John Goman.
If you ever get a chance, he'd be a good one to interview.
He was the campus minister here.
And the best description of John is he's a medieval monk transported by a time machine.
So he'd never pass through the analytical age of, say, Newton and Galileo,
the analysis, breaking it down into parts.
He fought holistically, you know?
And he didn't have any trouble with this.
We had these discussions for years.
The students would just come and people would come and meet at these discussions.
And so the non-linear world is a strange world.
It's a world that requires you to think more with the right hemisphere of your brain.
In my Gilchrist has a great video, people should look at it,
but divided brain.
And he says the left hemisphere is sequential linear.
And we have become dominated by left brain thinking.
Okay, I think that's true.
And he describes what kind of organization would you get
if it was dominated by left hemisphere.
And he describes, and as far as I'm concerned, it's the universe.
So the right hemisphere is just the world is so amazing.
It's just things emerge, and so anyhow, that's the stuff I got into.
But I wanted to get into it from the human perspective.
Big organizations.
I didn't want to stay in the mathematical modeling.
I kept teaching, I had to make a living.
I kept teaching the computer modeling, and I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed teaching.
But when I teach the even engineering mechanics,
I almost never brought in notes.
The class knows never.
The interact with the students.
And the best classes occurred when the course,
the class, went in the direction that I didn't even anticipate.
And it just got to keep my life.
And then the eyes light up when they get something as great.
It strikes me that you're placing an imperative on getting away
from the computer screen.
It's getting out and interacting with people.
It falls the same while your father took it.
Yeah, I think that's probably true.
Yeah, he really did.
He majored physics, heal, which had that time.
Physics.
I don't know how he did.
That's tough.
I mean, because physics, that time was going to a huge change.
And I brought him when he retired a pendulum in it.
He has several magnets, so it's a non-linear.
And it doesn't just swing back and forth.
It just goes in this.
And when he looked at that his eyes lit up and he just laughed and he says,
that would improve in my professor's crazy.
Yeah, so I did that.
It also sounds like there's a divergence between the curriculum that you're teaching,
or being compelled to teach in your research interest.
Oh, I have an opposite direction.
If I take my career at Oregon State, I can put all my accomplishments
in two piles.
A, that got me promotion and tenure.
It was full professor, tenure, all the rest of this.
A, right away.
Pile B over here didn't go anywhere within your sensation.
Or, you know, not very, not very far.
The most important pile is B.
You can throw out all the rest.
Now, I learned a lot by, say, teaching engineering mechanics.
And you learn a lot.
There, for example, in the tennis courses, the way we teach the math isn't that important.
You have to teach students how to sketch.
Make a sketch.
It's called a free body diagram.
Ask any student who's taking it.
You have to have to draw it.
So how do you make a sketch?
How do you think?
How do you do that?
You know?
And you engage the students in that, you know, making the simple sketches.
So when I went to study human systems, I'm going to make sketches.
Because the sketch is too dimensional.
Okay?
You know, it goes too dimensional sketch.
Now, you can make a free dimensional.
That's not too hard to go to free dimension.
But going from one dimension, which is a written text, to two dimensions, is a huge difference.
I mean, you can talk about something as perpendicular in two dimensions.
And that means this dimension cannot be reduced to this dimension.
They're orthogonal.
Well, in one dimensional lines of reasoning, you can't do that.
I mean, you can sort of say it, but you don't see it.
So the average board, typical book is what about a half mile long.
It's only one line.
It's only arranged on pages for convenience.
And so that shapes the way we think.
We think in lines.
And the world does not behave in lines.
The world is much more of this way.
Now, if you go on a construction site, I learned this my first job.
They give you a set of specs, all lines, right?
And a set of drawings.
I was never looked at the specs.
I was all over those drawings.
And if you go out on the construction site, watch construction on campus.
And you'll see people using body language.
You'll see them taking out diagrams.
They're not sitting around studying text professors to that.
But they could never build a building like that.
Well, I'm wondering if the system's theory.
I mean, my impression anyway, it could be wrong about this.
But it was sort of kind of the spine of your work.
And then that went off in a lot of different kind of more topical directions.
Or kind of current events eat types, directions that true.
Well, my work, I finally, a lot of the work in systems now is going highly sophisticated mathematics.
And the study of emergence, for example,
one of the best people of biology is Stuart Kaufman.
And he's done randomized Boolean networks.
He did some things, it's a mathematical.
And it's pretty good.
So, I've done some of that.
But I go, what's the point in all the math?
I mean, if we're trying to understand the world that people are living in,
then we ought to be able to communicate to them.
Because they know more about that world than we do.
So, what I do is I make sketches.
Okay?
And you make sketches.
And now I'll do like ten statements on a sketch.
Ten simple statements connected by arrows.
So they look.
Okay?
And I'll get people, if I can get them to read it.
The people who read it, no, no.
You just described my life.
This is what's going on.
So one of them that I did was how information gets distorted in organizations.
The classic example explanation we give is blame.
Look at the veterans administration.
Okay, information was distorted.
So what do they do?
They fire erection psyche.
I mean, he's got to be one of the most honest straightforward guys you can imagine.
I mean, he's an honorable person.
And I mean that in the best sense of the word.
And you listen to the congress, and there everybody's blaming everybody.
So what I did is I made a simple sketch.
And how organization is a system.
And it provides a context within which everybody finds reasons to behave in their own particular way.
But the system is a whole the store's information.
Okay?
That's what I do.
And that everybody inside of it has a good reason.
And there ordinary people like us.
So I've done that.
Mm-hmm.
I graduated visual one in late seventies.
And I first didn't publish it, but the model sort circulated,
and people would send me.
I got a zero X of the zero X can use send me a copy.
So then in 86 I think it was the shuttle block.
And I'm watching television and I see Bridget Fineman.
And he's trying to explain what's going on.
going on. He's describing my model. I never studied NASA. So I sent them a copy of the diagram
in this table and I didn't know he was dying as stomach cancer. I think it was not cancer
at the time. I wish I were to thank them, you know, so if you want to thank someone,
thank them quick when they die, I'll do it now. Thanks, Richard. Okay, and he read it and he
wrote me back this letter and he says, I read this table in a amazed perfect prediction.
No, I don't use perfect prediction, but if you're rich and fine, and you can use, you know,
you can use perfect prediction. And he says, I didn't realize that NASA was part of a general
phenomenon. Technically, if I said that, we'd say that's a grammatical error, a phenomena.
If Richard Feynman says it, it's brilliant. Okay, so then I started publishing it. Now next month,
I'll just I'll be going to Quebec City for the American Fisheries Society to present this model.
Okay, and I got a figure out how to do it on a PowerPoint now because it's going to be 2500 people
and I've got half an hour. So that's a little, I like to interact, but you know, you interact with
2500 people. So anyhow, I draw these models and when people can understand them and they see it,
then they can start telling you, because they know more about the experience in the world and I do,
they can start telling you. And to a large extent, what I'm doing is I'm providing an alternative
to blame and looking at these larger systems. Now it's consistent with a lot of the mathematics
that's going on. It's just that you can experience it in life. And if the world is not linear and
emergent, we are experiencing it. So we have to open up our eyes.
When one looks at sort of an abstracted, you've either, there are issues that are mostly in the past
now and wondering if what you've just described is, if these are examples of it happening,
that model have been applied in the past to things like space-based weaponry.
Yeah, I will see, I, that was an interesting, I, about the 1980s, some of the 1980s.
I was really getting frustrated with the environmental because, you know, that's about the time
that they started the global warming. We will make predictive models and scientists may say,
well, we really weren't, no, no, that's the way the objectives were written. I went back and
look at the original documents and we'll develop predictive models and I said, now you want to
this, you know, so I got frustrated. So I wanted to learn more about large-scale computer systems
and that cannot understand organizations by just observing. So I went and I spent six years
Ronald Reagan's Star Wars program and I had no funding. So I could go to the meetings and I didn't
have to hustle any money and oh, you go to these meetings and, you know, these consultants,
they're always half-thousand money. And so I could ask these questions and I said, I want to see
if I can, as a citizen, if I can find something, make a contribution here to something that
you know, they don't see. And I did find, I did, I could. And that's a whole other story in the
involves an interesting character, including Richard Cheney, who was Secretary Defense at the time.
So, and Richard Garwin, who designed the hydrogen bomb, interesting, really interesting guy.
So, I met some interesting people and I did some interesting things, but I was mainly interested
in these human systems and how, and then the large-scale technological ones and how we can lose control.
I mean, the control was sort of often in the lose.
You referenced earlier John Connor in West Mr. House in the local environment a little bit.
You want to talk more about him in that period of time?
Yeah, John Connor was a campus minister. He had been a minister in the Mexico.
It turns out he, I found that years later that he, he knew my cousin in return, I think, was
her a time in Mexico. And, and he had John was, he was very tall and I had this long beard.
He just would raise all sorts of questions. He raised all sorts of questions. He'd just be bouncing around
and he sort of stir up the pot. And we, at that particular time,
there was a whole national movement where theology, or mainline churches were challenging higher
education. There's a book on it, Douglas Sloan, Columbia University, it's called Faith in Knowledge.
And probably out of print now, but it's very good book. And they, they were challenging
higher education. And what Sloan writes about is that went on for about two decades.
And Eisenhower's learning is sort of right in the middle of that. So there was a time in there where
where people are are looking at the problems of technology. Yes, it has good things,
but we have to recognize this limitations too. And there was sort of this attitude there.
And so John played a key role in that. And he was mainly the facilitator of it. He became
moderator of the Presbyterian Church, which is, I guess, the highest position. And he, he, he would,
you know, he did a lot of interesting things. But for me, it was like he was sort of at the
focal point of the center of the world when we were all interesting things were happening.
So that was very important time. And there were concepts that came up in very, very important.
I wrote a paper published in 2006 on evil. Evil in a time.
Well, this was a, it's a secular germ. I mean, it's, it's on emergency evils, the dilapidate.
And I use concepts from theology in there. And no one raised any concern.
It was, you know, they were helping us to understand this, this phenomenon. And basically,
I was saying that evil, large patterns emerge. And ordinary people like you and I get caught up
within them. And in biblical language that would be bondage of blindness, you're caught up within it.
And you can't transcend it transcend the context, the system that you're caught up within.
And horrible things could be done. And the example I use was a Soviet biological warfare system.
And it is horrible things. And by some top scientists, so scientists can get caught up in it just like anybody else.
Anyhow, that, you know, that probably has goes back in some ways to John Connor.
It's interesting how often you've been working with church groups.
I'm on the French. It's French and church groups. I, you know, I, I don't go regularly to
services, but they're, see, part of it, I'm studying models. Well,
I learned models as a kid. They were called parables.
A parable is a model. All models are simplifications. And what they do is help to clarify some
matters of importance, not all. And they expose their limitations. Okay? So a parable is a story.
What you do is you get engaged in the power you learn to get, you know, you don't think much of
an engagement. And then as you're going through life, you begin to see something.
And that's what the purpose of, of a good model really is that you play with it to engage in it.
And then it allows you to become aware of something. And it's very different than having a big computer
that no one knows what it's doing and it spits out data. So in that sense, what I was involved
was, had its roots there in parables. But also, in engineering, you know,
scientists act like all the stuff that we build here and all the stuff comes out of science.
Okay? And, uh, whereas I would say yes, but I thought engineering mechanics, Newtonian
mechanics, when engineers build, like the buildings on campus, just go watch their amazing
and build them on campus. Okay? We also use safety factors. And we don't talk about students don't
know about this. And we're to safety factors come from, they come from confession and repentance.
You know, confession repents is an analophole. It's not self-blame. It means you've done something
and there's a failure. What are you going to do? You admit to the failure and you change your ways.
And that's how you learn. That's how you learn how to write a bike. You know, study bicycle writing,
the theory of bicycle writing, and pass a quiz, a multiple grade, you know, a multiple choice
quiz and say, now I'm a bike writer. You get on it and you fall down. That's how life is. And so
in engineering, similar engineering in particular, if you look at the history, you see all these
pictures of bridges that fell down, you'd begin to say, what's going on here? That's how we learn.
And there's a historian, uh, uh, engineering. And he has some statements. He read one the other day
behind every, almost every success is a history of failure, something like this.
Well, that's probably pretty good theology, too. So there's been a whole part. It's not about
belief systems. And they even churches get that wrong. You know, the word belief is a modern word.
You know, the word religion, even. I mean, you know, it's a new word. I mean, no one that's
less than 100 years. As a system of belief, it just doesn't make sense. So, uh, what you learn
with stories and and parables, and you went out into the world, and you made mistakes. Guess what?
So that's how you learn. So when I, when I come back to some stuff that I learned in church and
stuff that I learned in engineering and stuff that I learned in environment, there are some
common things. Now, what's absent is some of this foolishness like intelligent design or things like
this. And this, this is just a big distraction. I mean, you know, I mean, John Connor had no problem
with evolution. I father didn't. Now, maybe his father maybe did, but a lot of people did things change.
So I, I've sort of been on the fringe of some, some, I guess you call theological insights
that are pretty cool. There's some interesting ones. And they're not about belief systems. And one of
one of the things you find now, for example, is how Buddhism and Christianity have parts of it,
is just sort of come together and read discovery each other. And you take a guy like Richard
Rourer, who's a friend, Syskin Catholic, and he will talk about the Dalai Alama, the Dalai Alama,
the Dalai Alama. I mean, this is like, you know, the boxes we put people in, it just doesn't
make sense. So, thank you. Tell me about the swallowed camel club. Oh, the swallowed camel club.
Okay. Okay, the swallowed camel club. We had a group that is spontaneously met many years ago.
I don't know how many. First of the library, we would make it almost too much in the ways.
And so we, so we started meeting over at the St. Anne's Office, Episcopal Campus District,
because John Connor, our time, John Goldman, was John Goldman. And he's the guy that's this medieval
monk. And we were, people were, we raised certain questions and say, I say, well, are you getting
this in your classes? I got no. So if you really want to find out what's being taught, you have to ask the students,
ask the students. So the stuff on complexity and all of the rest of these big-scale systems,
those, you know, they're not addressing all things. Not really. Not in a way that registers
with the students. I mean the student. Okay. So we have had these discussions. So what are we going to
call our group? Well, there's an ancient criticism of university professors. You blind guides.
You strain out a mat and swallow a camel. Okay. It's gospel same Matthew. Okay. And it's right
hemisphere. It's got a metaphor, blind guide. You strain out a mat, swallow a camel. Three mat
forces. That's the right hand. And he puts them together in irony and humor. And yet, people go, yeah.
So obviously a camel is not the sum of a lot of little nets. So it's not linear. So anyhow,
we would laugh and sort of be the joke we called this whole camel club. And we're not meeting
this summer. And it's going on pretty strong. The last several months though, we've sort of dropped
off and part of it. I've been working on some other stuff. And part John Goldman has retired,
physical churches going through some changes. So I'm not sure where it's going to go. But it has
gone on for years. And there's still, I got a email list of 30, 40 people who would
plong to it. I sent it out. Did you have any contact with Katherine Jefford's story? Yeah,
a little bit of contact with Katherine Jefford's story. And Dick's story, he was a mathematics
or husband and non-linear of dynamics. But not much on this. Not much on this. She's done a,
you know, an outstanding job. And certainly on making the, I'm not a physical family, but
making the physical church work, certainly for open days and less means. And she's, she's really
done that and had to fight some battles. And she does it very, very graciously, very graciously.
I would say I'd love to get, she also has a PhD in oceanography. I would also be fun to have
in conversation with the fair and then to say Marcus Borg and all the other Marcus Borg.
Because I would be a little more questioning of science than I think they are. It's not that
science back. It's just that, that there's a lot of specialization and a lot of claims.
It does wonderful things. But not everything. And we could, we could have an interesting discussion.
I want to ask you about a couple kind of bullet points from your beat of past research interests
that I think have particular bookability to people in this state. The first one is an issue that's
been important to folks. My set of state needs to know again that's destruction of chemical weapons.
Oh yeah, that's an interesting story. So I got invited on this one. I actually got paid for this one.
You know, I'm not a whole lot. But a lot of the work I did I didn't get paid for, I just did it.
And I make my living teaching. The United States had millions of
literally millions and millions of chemical munitions stored all over. And I mean, they say their weapons
most of them are not usable. And one of them, for example, the M55 rocket, they mean half a million
of them. It's about a seven foot rocket, about six, seven feet. And it's not guided. And they don't
even have launchers. And the thing I think tends to go like this. So they got all these rockets.
Well, what are you going to do with them? And they got, they have the warheads with the chemical
agent inside of it. So you got like a liquid and you got a birch there because it's an aerosols.
I'm not really a gas. And then you got this old booster rocket. And they've riveted the
warheads on. So they can't just unscrew them. So they have to get rid of them. So I was part of a
independent team to review the risk analysis. Because they want to know whether they should
ship them off site or destroy them on site and incineration and all the rest of us. Well,
one of the things I looked at was the M55 rocket. And they had these big steel insulated containers
to transport them. And they had on wood pallets. So I don't know if they might have that 15 on a pallet
and two pallets might 30. So they'd have 15 or 30 inside when they'd be. And they had tests.
So they could drop it from 20 feet. And if there's a fire could insulate, they went through
all these accident scenarios. Well, the way they do risk analysis is they break it down into
a different rule. What's the probability of this? The science of this job. What's the probability
of this? And they put them all together to find the probability of an accident occurring,
which requires maybe three or four or five different things happening. So it's a low probability.
And a lot of the stuff to have to pull out in the air. Like what's the probability of an
airplane crashing into one of these igles or these storage bins? Well, they have to figure out how many
planes crashing into the air. So the one I came up with is, okay, what happens to the rockets
if there is a train wreck? Well, don't worry. So the warhead, you know, we've checked the warhead
on this thing and we won't go off. I said, I'm not worried about that. I'm worried about
the rocket igniting inside and it turns out that when they set up the system, they didn't put
a box for that. So because all that won't happen. That won't happen. That won't happen.
So you go over the meeting and when they say, oh, that won't happen. Wait for the coffee break.
Wait for the coffee break. Because then somebody comes up, why don't you go check? I've heard
this. They say this. So anyhow, I end up in Tuala, Utah and they're going to go in on a tour
of the incineration, but you have to work cast mass and they want me to shade my beard and
say, oh, I don't want to shave my beard. So will we be out here? Will this leave you with this guy?
That's good. They leave you with somebody. This guy tests these warheads.
It's very ingenious design of the warhead, you know, the fused, the fused. But in the process,
I learned that, but I was concerned is inside the, if you have a crash, all these rockets start
smashing around, then you take steel and you bend it. It gives off heat. So is it possible that
in the twisting of the metal, you'll get enough heat to ignite the rocket? Because all the
rocket really is, is solid booster inside a steel tube. And it's a slow explosion. The gas goes
out the bottom. So I had done some calculations, rough calculations, you know, how much heat would
begin off, you puncture the steel casing, and then how much temperature would rise in the steel
right around it, and compared that to the ignition temperature of the rocket and it was higher.
So, if you were to say, oh, there's no data on that. Well, when they say there's no data,
sorry, that may be, you know, we've never seen the data, or we've never collected the data,
or it doesn't mean that they shouldn't be. Anyhow, I find out that to this guy, and I get the
field notes, that they test these rockets by dropping 20 of them, and three of them ignited.
Three ignited. And I heard some stories about them trying to test the warhead, you know,
so they get a guy to shoot a rifle at the warhead, and sometimes he misses in his the rocket
and so the rocket takes stock, but they didn't have a box to put this in. So they get the number
three out of 20. So you get a probability, three out of 20, it's like three by 20, and I said,
I've seen that number before, because I go through all these calculations sheets, and I come and
I find that number, and they say, oh, that's the probability of a warhead going out of my
rocket release. It gives a reference. I look up this reference. And what happened is, everybody started
referencing everybody else, and what started out as a rocket ignition ended up as the warhead
got off. Okay. And of course, if it's the rocket igniting, and there's 15 or 30 other rockets
inside, it's still contained. You got a bomb, okay, because they can only hold like three rockets
igniting. So we pointed out that to them, and so that was kind of interesting, because it
illustrates that the science that gets done depends to a large extent on how the organization
of it is structured and funded. And if everybody says, gee, that's an interesting idea, but it's
not my job. That means it's not being done. Everybody has a good reason why they're not doing it.
But what happens is the organizational structure in a sense can direct us, ask certain questions,
and not do other questions. And then when those questions come up, occasionally, people can just
dismiss us on my job. So we'd better change the organization. That's not my job. It's the
organization to big. I can't change it. And so what happens is the problems continue. Now fortunately,
they've managed to get rid of all the M55 rockets. They did not transport them. So we got the right
decision. You know, we brought that. And how much of my response state, we eroded up and how much
of it survived through the bureaucratic process. Some of it did, some of it didn't. So I don't know.
But it was fascinating that I learned a lot about risk analysis and organizational structure.
So they're doing a good job. And I mean, they had to get incinerated because these rockets
they put a stabilizer in them. But if that stabilizer degrades and they think it does,
I mean, the rockets go off. And they're all stored together. That's not good. They had literally
millions of millions of emissions. So when you read in the paper of the Soviet Union and the United
States arguing about who's, you know, have the weapons and so forth. What they should have
been saying was, here you take it. No, you take it. No, I don't want them. You take it. I mean,
they were billion dollar problem. Okay, potential disaster. And, you know, that was interesting.
Yeah. So what other bullet? I want to ask about salmon in the idea of salmon parks.
Oh, yeah, salmon. Well, I've worked a lot with fisheries biologists and largely because once I started
studying these human systems, I didn't get any research grants. So I done my travel money. So
salmon's a local one and we had some very fine people here in salmon. So the American fisheries
society back in 2005, they published it in 2006, but somewhere before then they basically said,
we've been trying, we've been trying to protect wild salmon and we spent billions of dollars
and it's not working. So we want to select 33 people from out the country and even maybe
outside the country, but mainly Canada and the United States and Northwest. What would you do?
They're totally free to say, what would you do? Okay. And so I was 100. Okay.
So Bob Lacky, he's over there in political science and fisheries. He was the
director and Denise Locke, who was on it. So, so Bob, so they framed the problem.
The problem is, how do we have significant numbers of wild salmon by the year 2100? And then
he had four policy guides and one of them, or four policy drivers, okay, something that
means. And one of them was, people are going to have to change their preferences,
their values, their preferences. So I went through the whole thing and I basically
concluded that the way they framed the problem, you can't sell the problem. Okay, we're not going to sell
it. And besides the problem numbers of wild salmon, that's not the real problem. The problem
is, what kind of world do we want to leave future generations? And the whole business about
preferences, I said, no, we're going to get outcomes that no one prefers. So, so what I did is,
I reframe the problem. Now that's kind of like you're being given a test in the go on in the
side, I can't answer this question, so I'm going to change the question, and I'm supposed to do that.
So, but I did it, and I got to give them credit, they kept the paper in there. So,
basically what I had to do is, I thought it would be real easy, I'll just say,
of wild salmon national park. That's what we need. But I, in order to do that, I had to challenge
all the ways that we're thinking, which are linear ways of thinking. A wild salmon national park
is doable. We have all sorts of agencies doing all sorts of things, like the Corps of Engineers
since mitigation sites. We don't even know where they are. Okay, if you pull that money together
and you could buy up, particularly high-flug-prone areas, which are the best habitats,
all the way throughout the whole north west, and you would have a distributed wild salmon
national park. Okay, even through cities, people want their waterfronts. So, you know, it wouldn't be
total of natural systems, but, and there are a whole sorts of flood zones, and you look at the
lamb and river, and you see all these different twists and turns, and the farmers have trouble
farming there because they flood, they plant all these weeds, but they call weeds, which
and biologists call the natural floor. Okay, it's really funny. And if you look at the people who are
studying floods and they map out high-flug-prone areas, and we got to prevent development to
do something about that, and then you go over to the wildlife biologists and take their maps of
ideal habitat, and they almost overlap. So it's a no-brainer. Okay, why don't we just buy some of
this land and pay the people, you know, not to build there rather than putting concrete or rock
rip wrap along the banks because it may erode. So I went through a whole bunch of those things, and I
basically found that we could have a wild salmon national park, and it would run right through
different parts of the whole Pacific Northwest, and try and let the salmon come back, let the salmon
guys. The biggest resistance seemed to come from the science, and it wasn't about the science,
everybody agreed we have to protect habitat, but they would say nobody's going to support the
people don't prefer that. Well, I took that and said, how do you know? Okay, first it's not about
preferences. The amount of money is patents. I took the comparatively the whole national park budget for
that year. It's minor. I may get the numbers wrong, but five billion, let's just say. Okay.
And then I compared the bonuses given to Goldman Sachs, one bank is like 20 billion. Okay,
is much big. Here's the national park, the whole national market. Here's the, here's the
bonuses given to Goldman Sachs, the year before the whole system crashed. Okay, I don't think the
people even in Goldman Sachs think that that's make sense, but you say, oh people want. And then
the same year that we polt finally published this, PBS did a special, a national parks, America's
best idea. So basically I conclude that the reason we don't have that is because the institutions
of frame the problem in pieces. So everybody can say it's not my job. And then everybody can blame
everybody else. And then everybody can focus on their little job. Now there is a guy who could
be interesting to interview, I don't know, David Lane, because he did his PhD dissertation on
reframing and he used the same in 2100 as his test case. And he's got brilliant idea. He basically said
if there are environmental problems that we have not been able to solve, we've probably
framed the problem in the wrong way. It's like if I give an exam question to my engineering students
and at the end of the exam period, all my smart students are still trying to solve the problem,
I'm in trouble because I framed the problem in a way they can't solve. So what he wanted to do
is to look back over the history and find reframings because we will lose them because the
institutions frame the problem in a particular way. So if someone comes along and reframes it,
everybody may say it's a good idea, but he gets lost in the institution. So he developed software
to get indicators of reframing and he could have a software search through with these indicators
to try to find a radical reframing and identify it and use the same in 2100 as an example.
And as indicators go like this and then my paper came out like this, so that's how I got to move.
So he's working over there with international students with English teaching English.
I'm asking a couple more questions about OSU. Your research interests in your contacts,
primary contacts, it seems we're pretty far afield from traditional civil engineering.
Did you ever feel isolated or like a man at that home on some level?
Yeah, you do sometimes. The hardest thing over the years,
people act like, well if you do this, you know, somebody's going to fire you then, that's not the problem.
I, you know, I never had the problem. No, I was fortunate because
maybe because of my family, but I could teach. And so I get real high course evaluations.
So that sort of protected me. And because if you're not bringing in research dollars,
it's going to be pretty hard to survive, but I was able to do that sort of, there's some interesting stories on that.
Well, I'll tell you one story. Some of the Columbia areas that he yesterday studied.
And Guy Daniel Hancock and I were, were some contractors for, I said, this is a dangerous project.
I'm only going to be a subcontractor for the interactions, the biophysical interactions.
How's all this stuff interact? And so we're looking at the project and then mail these grants out there.
And none of it's going to interact because their people are just doing their own thing.
So we come up with a scheme which we develop hypothesis systems.
I said, well, have an annual meeting. And Dan and I put up these hypothesis systems about a problem.
And we'll present it to the whole group. And I said, well, follow the bell of cooking rule.
Anybody who doesn't like it gets to do the next time. Anybody who complain. So you end up with
these, you know, everybody interacts and we end up with these hypothesis systems. And then you
reallocate the funding based upon whether you're going to actually be able to address these hypotheses.
So it's sort of a learning process. So there's a, in that story, there's going to be a workshop
there. And so the manager of the project, he says, okay, you will meet for the first
after the half of the day. And I'll do the second half of the day or vice versa.
You'll do half a day. We'll do half a day. So we said, okay, so we prepared this for the citizen's
advisory group. And there are people in there who are fishermen and local people there. I mean,
they know a lot about the history. They know a lot more than I do, but
so we present this to them. Oh, when we get down there, the manager says, you do the whole day.
I'm not going to do anything. So I think he was thinking he was going to drop something on us,
but actually, he said, great. So we do the workshop. And they loved it because his fishermen,
I mean, they had ideas on this. And we're sketching them out and they said, now we can be involved
in this and we can actually see, you can come to these meetings. And so the meeting ends
and we go out to eat and the manager's there. And I didn't realize we didn't pick up on his,
we're usually pretty good at picking up on body language, but Dan and I are still talking. We don't
realize how angry he is. Because this means our approach, he has to reorganize the boxes and he's got
them all lined up. And I didn't realize how angry he was until we're eating and all of a sudden
he loses it. He jumps up and throws his briefcase on me. So which I catch and throw it back at him.
And he storms out. Well, needless to say, we didn't get funded, but the whole project crashed.
But the interesting part is apparently, if I remember right, my promotion committee was meeting
like the week before. So on the record, I had this grant. So I was able to speak by, I guess,
I don't, but I made it. So, but now you were getting by a little strack of the question,
how do I feel it already, Satan? The hardest thing to deal with are the stone face.
You bring up an interesting idea, something that you think is important, and you get a plan.
Blank. And I noticed this when David Lane would go with me, since you got the stone face.
And I think what happens is I'm not sure what's really going on here, but people become so focused on their
little feel that the grooves in their brain gets so deep and it just doesn't register. Or they may say,
oh, you'll just have to read our literature. It's just, it's just not there.
So it's been sort of a lack of exciting discourse, I think, that's probably been the hardest thing to do with.
That's, and that takes a toll. There is a story on this, David Lane.
David, big lie at the huge guy. No one wants to take him on, so David Shepherd boy comes up.
Sit on, take him on. So first thing he puts on the king's armor and he can't move.
We put on a lot of armor. We can't move either. Like academic citations and references in the
academic language and mathematical equations he can't move. So he takes off the armor.
Goes there, picks up and gets some stones. And of course the story goes,
Slice, go, I have to say, yeah, but what about the other stones? They don't tell you that.
See, they lead parts for years, both of you land. So I'll tell you what happened to the other stones.
First stone. He missed. That's what life is about. You missed.
So then, second stone. This is, well, he hit him, made a really mad. Okay.
Third stone. So this is the one that's most painful. This is what's worse than hitting him and getting
really mad. Get it? Thank you, shot. Hit him right between the eyes. He doesn't even notice.
And he says, that really wears on for a long time. So I'm at the end of my talk, you know, someone said
someone who knew the story better. There's another stone.
What? Yeah, there's a fourth one. What did that one do? I don't know. I don't know.
So my wife is there. And I just leave. I come home.
She goes back and she says, I know what the fourth stone was.
Is the Holy Rolling Stone like a what? She put on this music. And it was from
TV show, John of Arcadia or something that we're got appears to people is the janitor or somebody
like this. And it's like a Holy Rolling Stone. And so I still don't get it. He says, he dropped it.
And it became the Holy Rolling Stone for someone else to pick up. And that's a whoa, that's cool.
But anyhow, the the painful part is often this is being seeing that there are some really
big challenging problems. And then just not being able to sustain this course. That's the hardest part
of the story. We've seen a lot of change in OSU. And this is a season of change for the
university as well. And warning me, just in your perspective, I'm kind of where the
universities come from, where it's heading. Yeah, well, they've done a very good job in the campus
and landscape. I think the campus and landscape is really remarkable. I think they've
really much given up on the idea of educating and learning knowledgeable citizenry. You
have to have discourse in order to do this. I think they're really
very close ties with industry. I think Brian Adams, who was the Dean of Engineering,
very close ties in the industry. He's now, I guess, the vice president or something now.
And it's not that that's bad, but it's sort of like, it's unbalanced. And there has to be some
other role where the university does some unique things that no one else can do. And I think
they've forgotten. And I think a good people embrace good person, Steve Clarks, good
versions. But what I find in the systems is systems of dance. So the people who are very successful
in them, in a sense, become part of the system, far more than they realize. They become not just
in the system, but out of the system. And it's just too easy to start believing your own hype.
And that's sort of danger. And you need scouts. You need somebody, I used to tell President's
custard biggest mistake, a little big horn, as he didn't listen to his scouts.
And the scouts, somebody who's not fucking for higher position. And the only time you really
need a scout is to tell you something you don't want to hear that you're going in the wrong direction.
You don't need someone applauding the direction you're going in. And so I think there's an absence
of scouts that are out there that are willing to do it. And I consider myself a scout. And
I'm not a leader in the sense I don't have lots of people following me. And I'm not a follower.
I go out and explore. And that's important. So we are testing with, I'm always trying something,
but with one idea. And working with Charlie Vars, former mayor, and economist, and court
smithing anthropologists, and it has to do with the awarding. And we have many, many, probably thousands
over the years of students from the places particularly China coming here. Very conscientious,
main going back. Let's get it. So the question is, where are they really learning when they come here?
I mean, this place blows their mind. This is totally different. And they're, first of all,
they're wealthy, they're a lot. Okay, so it's not, you know, it's not the peasants coming from China,
but that I grew up with, I mean, by some pretty nice cars. And they're living in a place that
in any place else in the world would be called core heaven. Core palace, I mean, we talk about
our parking process. I mean, compared to the rest of the world, this is nothing. So they're learning
something, like being here. And I think they're learning the wrong lessons. Okay, they're learning,
this is how things are done. And if they're in civil engineering, they're probably being taught
how to do it. So we came up with a proposal. And basically, that Oregon State University and the
city of Gravals in the county would develop some of no car communities. Surve by rail line,
we have an existing rail line. That existing rail line goes north, goes right through the middle of
town, goes through the southern end of campus, and right through a piece of property, bigger than
the campus, the university owns most of it. And then further, okay, you built a clustered,
no car community. I don't know the scale. You want to get a scale that is viable neighborhood scale,
so that if you were building a mega city, that would be sort of the scale in the neighborhood.
Okay, so I don't have a 1500 to 3000 something. And what you do is you involve the students
in the design of this. And in doing it, we are telling them the way we have developed this
has been a mistake. Okay, this cannot continue. And we are going to do it for ourselves. We're not
lecturing you that you ought to do something that we've done, you know, that you shouldn't do what we've
done. What we're doing is we're asking for your help to help sign a viable community here in
Carvals that would involve students involved faculty and some citizens from town. The rail line is
all the way through there. It's already there. How could we use it? What could be the way to do it?
And what we would do is involve the students in lessons learned. They go look to all of
the world. What were the successes and failures? There's a couple of cities in China that
went just to get to pretty much a walkable city, but there's also some disasters in China.
So you learn from those. Okay, lessons learned. And then you get some of them to start building
a virtual examples of this. They can take towards. There is a program where it's a construction
program. I don't know whether you're familiar. I'm not in the video gaming. But Atlantic had a magazine.
And of course, it's an imaginary world. You know, monsters and all the restants. But they build
stuff. Why not make a real one? They have 100 million participants in this thing. That's more
there all the university students in the United States. Okay? So what you would do is you make this
part of their effort. And what they would do is to say, you want to understand the local culture.
This is the university town. We have a campus. Some good examples. How can you build on the
architectural success of a campus? So that when they went back, they'd say, what's the local
culture? How do we build on the success of that local culture? How do we do this? No, we don't need
to have animal bills. And you can serve it in different ways and have viable communities.
So anyhow, we've written up a proposal. So one page both sides. And then we've written a memo
which we gave to Steve Clark. Okay? And I doubt whether it would be when anywhere. But we're going
to start spreading it out. And we've been meeting on this for about a year now every week over the
magic. So we're, we're it's going to go, I don't know. But you know, it's doable. It's doable.
When you look at, when you look at the satellite photographs, if they could Google,
Google, whatever it is, Earth, Google Earth, you look around and you say, there's a
thing like, it goes right by, right by a parking garage. I mean, how ironic, right by a parking
garage and that right on through this piece of land, you could have open space, farm space,
all around it. And then there's, there's another one just near fuel at the back. And then you look
at the side of fuel at the back, it is, you know, it's about half parking spaces. Most of the
empty now. Anyhow, that's, that's some of the stuff that will work. Well, my last question for you
is, as you think about the future, are you able to stay optimistic? Okay, this is a good question.
There's a big difference between optimism and hope. Okay. And there's a Cornell West,
he's a field surgeon for you. And he's black. And he says, I cannot be optimistic
but I am totally hopeful. Hope requires courage to act when doubt is warranted. Okay,
now David Lane found that when he did his thesis. And when I was in a class, his honest
class, and David Lane presented that to that class, their jaws dropped. And they said, why
hasn't anybody told us that? So optimism, it's, it's, it's hard for me to just be optimistic.
But optimism involves what the Buddhist call attachment, you're attaching to the outcome.
So you don't want to attach to the outcome. I realize an engineering, you know,
it's supposed to attach to the outcome. But engineering can do with big problems and do with a lot of little ones.
The little ones don't add it, the little ones may be good, but they don't, that doesn't mean that the hole is good.
The world would linear, that would make sense for the world would linear. I can be a great musician,
because I can play great notes on a grand piano, but when I add up all the notes, it's terrible music.
So the world is non-linear. So I'm hopeful, and I'm hopeful, and what you do is you've done
to attach the outcomes, and you do something creative. You try to make a contribution in there,
and you don't, you know, of course sometimes you feel bad if it doesn't work.
But I look back, and if I look at all the failures, if you want to say that they didn't go anywhere,
now some of them did, but, and if I had to do it over again, I do it the same way. So there's no regrets.
So I guess if you approach, you know, I'm 75 now, you approach that is, and you don't have regrets,
and you say, no, I wouldn't trade what I've done with anybody else I know.
That's pretty good, but if, if I ask me, okay, well, I want to just list all your accomplishments.
No, I, I don't think that's the right question.
Now, again, that gets to be some theological, that, that, in Cornell West, I hope it's a
courage to act when doubt is warranted. And then, I hope also comes as a gift, freely a gift,
but that's what they call grace. So I don't know what I'm going to turn out, but I don't have to know.
Okay, and the idea of prediction and control is just an illusion. It's just, it's just, yeah, yeah,
if you're building a cabin, maybe that's okay, but we're talking about the future, the Earth and society's,
just, just don't do that. So we need to tell that to the students,
our generation, you should tell it.
Well, thank you very much. This has been a lot of fun, and I appreciate you being so generous
with the time and walking around. Well, I, I would again, anybody who looks at this, that the oral
history is extremely important because there are a lot of things that didn't make it into all the
documents that they're studying. And they may be the important things, it's kind of what
Sherlock Holmes, the dog, they didn't bark. Okay, the stuff that you don't find, why didn't you find it?
Well, that could be the world, a lot from that. Okay, well good, I appreciate it. Thanks. Thank you.